la novia de verano se ha ido olivia
newton-john que pasó a la historia del
cine y la música gracias al musical
adolescente wish murió a los 73 años en
su hogar de california luego de más de
tres décadas de lucha contra el cáncer
de mama
nacida en reino unido- y residente por
muchos años en australia ganó cuatro
premios grammy y vendió más de 100
millones de discos saltó a la fama con
su papel de sandy la novia de john
travolta en brillantina o vaselina como
se conoció en español en 1974 participó
en el concurso eurovisión representando
el reino unido- y terminó cuarta en un
año en el que la banda sueca abba se
impuso sanz de la catapultó pero no lo
encasilló una y otra vez fue capaz de
reinventarse sorprendió al pasar de la
inocente adolescente enamorada a la
mujer empoderada en físico a comienzos
de los 80
[Música]
y de física el para los para la época
era muy sexual algunas personas dicen
que incluso dice la leyenda el vídeo de
física la luz de entes los juntaba con
un poquito de vaselina para que no
fluyera como tan transparente la cosa
porque la gente sudando haciendo
ejercicio todos con los torsos pues
desde 12 demás eso era pesadísimo para
la época en que salió el sencillo pero
la reinvención que le tocó a principios
de los 90 fue la que definitivamente la
marcó cuando el cáncer de seno le fue
diagnosticado por primera vez con el
tiempo se involucró en causas
caritativas junto a su esposo john
easterling se convirtió en una ferviente
defensora del uso medicinal del cannabis
y resolvió la experiencia de su lucha
contra el cáncer en su autobiografía
mira ya el viaje de una mujer su
compañero en la pantalla john travolta
la despidió en nombre propio y de danny
su enamorado cinematográfico mi
queridísima olivia mejorarse mucho
nuestras vidas su impacto fue increíble
te veremos en el camino y estaremos
todos juntos de nuevo tuyos desde el
primer momento en que te vi y por
siempre dudan y tú y yo